There are so many new beauty releases
happening all the time,
so we gathered some of
the most-hyped products
to test for ourselves.
Em Cosmetics re-released
its Color Drops Serum Blush
with a new-and-improved
formula and packaging.
The old packaging was
notoriously difficult to use.
It had this dropper thing
that just would not dispense properly.
This new dropper is so much better.
You do have to build this blush up,
but it gives you a really
pretty, dewy flush of color.
I honestly can't see a difference
between the old formula and the new one,
this new one is just easier to use.
I'm not super into this
kind of blush formula.
I prefer the brand's powder
or cream blush over this.
But it's pretty, and it
didn't break up my foundation.
I've been dying to test out
the new Haus Labs foundation,
I've heard nothing but amazing things,
and I was not disappointed.
I went in with my foundation brush first,
and this just totally blends
into the skin seamlessly.
The coverage is on the lighter side,
so I added a little more,
and I am really impressed
by how weightless it is.
It has skincare ingredients in it,
and it actually feels like skincare.
It feels like you have
absolutely nothing on your face.
All of my other products
blended on top of this beautifully.
So this foundation is
a 10 out of 10 for me.
I also got the Bio-Blurring
Loose Setting Powder,
and I love this too.
It definitely does blur the
skin and sets your makeup
without making it look dry or cakey.
It's so soft and finely milled,
and it's also talc-free, which is great.
I tried a couple lip
products from Fenty Beauty,
the Gloss Bomb Heat Universal
Lip Luminizer and Plumper
in Hot Chocolit Heat
and the Gloss Bomb Ice
Cooling Lip Luminizer
in Cold Heart'd.
Let's talk about this
new Gloss Bomb Ice first.
It looks like a pale blue color,
but it goes on totally clear.
It has a really nice minty scent.
You get that cooling effect
instantly, and I like it.
It also feels great on the lips,
like the other Fenty glosses,
just super hydrating and shiny.
The Gloss Bomb Heat is not a new formula,
but people have been loving
the Hot Chocolit Heat shade.
It's like a brown with a
hint of rosiness to it.
Because it's on the more sheer side,
this color looks incredible
on so many different skin tones,
and it actually does plump
the lips really nicely.
It's not an uncomfortable
plumping effect at all.
A few of you asked if I could
review Mooncat polishes,
so I have a few to talk about.
This first one is called Illusionist,
and it's a magnetic multichrome.
I feel like Mooncat always has
these really interesting colors like this
that I don't see very often.
The magnetic effect on
this one is so cool.
I couldn't stop staring at my nails.
This next shade is called Cyclone,
and it's a blue-jelly flaky polish.
The way these iridescent
flakes look in this jelly
really give you this ocean vibe,
so I loved this one too.
The last polish I tried was Emo for Life,
which is just a plain black crème polish.
I honestly feel like this
one impressed me the most,
because it was literally
pitch black in one coat.
The pigment on it is incredible,
and the formula is so smooth.
The prices do vary
depending on the formula,
but overall, the quality of
the polish is really good,
and I also love the brush
and handle on these bottles.
They make it super easy to paint my nails.
This is the Charlotte
Tilbury Take It All Off.
It's a biphase makeup remover,
and I had to Google what that meant,
because I had no idea.
It basically means you get
an oil and water in one,
and you have to shake the
product to combine it.
It specifically says this is
for eyes, lashes, and lips.
You have to shake it,
apply it to a cotton pad,
and soak the area for a few
seconds for an easy removal.
This honestly worked really well,
and I tried it on waterproof mascara,
which always takes me forever to remove.
I also have very sensitive eyes,
and this didn't irritate them at all.
I liked this, but I think
it's a little too pricey
for a makeup remover
you're only supposed to use
on your eyes and lips.-
Saie just drop these Lip Blurs.
They're matte lipsticks
that you can build up
to be super-full coverage
or dab on for a soft, blurred lip.
I used the shade Modern first
and just dabbed it on with my finger.
It gave this really
pretty soft wash of color.
This other one, in the shade
Classic, really shocked me
because it's so smooth and pigmented.
I was laughing because I
definitely went too far
over my lip line, but we move.
I would recommend a lip liner with these,
because the formula isn't
as matte as you'd expect
and it does move around a little.
Overall, I think these are nice
and feel good on the lips.